this is a production of cornell
university
i'm going to talk to you about something
about you know this idea of kind of
going small the sustainability
of local breeding and this is a question
uh that uh that uh
really i started thinking about after
coming to hawaii
where everything is small it's a it's a
very small regional market
and so through to three three uh
vignettes here i'm gonna hopefully uh
convince you of some of my ideas
surrounding uh
uh breeding for for these these local
markets
so really there are two hypotheses that
that i'm really
hoping to explore um the
the first is that breeding for various
uh for very large geographies
is actually limited yield potential that
breeding for broad adaptation
and that really breeding for small
geographies
uh provides an avenue to increase
revenue and
and build community act uh community
and and kind of repair uh
some historic bad practices um
but let's start off with the first one
um and i'm gonna go back to some
some papers uh that i really enjoyed
reading when i went when i was in grad
school
uh the first is is levins when he talks
about
uh when there's a difference between the
environments
uh is large compared to the tolerance
for environmental
diversity the most fit population will
be a mixture of specialists
right so this is in some of his work
when he's exploring
fitness and fitness sets um
and so and so really
this means the most fit population in
any given
environment is going to be multiple you
know narrowly adapted varieties
um so this is this this can be displayed
in a number of different ways but but
really we're thinking about uh fitness
sets
we're thinking about um you know looking
at the interactions
uh that uh basically crossover
interactions in our fitness between our
different environments
we're looking at uh you know obviously
in our environment
in in our uh our fitness is going to
come along this gradient
and what levins propose right is that if
you look at
many many different genotypes uh if you
see over if we see our fitness and
environment a and fitness and
environment b if we have a convex
fitness set
we're going to have broad adaptation uh
and basically um there's not gonna be
that much difference between the
environments
but if we have a concave fitness set
local adaptation
uh we're gonna have high environmental
variants and this is going to
be what this is going to determine
what's going to be fit in most
populations
so at the same time that levins was
publishing this
you have in the plant breeding
literature finland wilkinson talking
about stability
right so you have from their 1963 paper
the ability of some crop varieties
to perform well over a range of
environmental conditions
has long been appreciated by the
agronomist and plant breeder
so basically this is your argument for
your we want a single broadly adapted
variety
right right in line with uh the green
revolution uh
you know um and so their their
conceptualization of this was to plot
uh many many uh so this is
uh to plot many many different varieties
and then to overlay in space
uh where uh the different geographies
like
and and in in general
um and hopefully all of you students
uh who are here can appreciate that it's
much easier to make figures now than it
was in the in the 60s
um but in in general this
can be displayed like you'd see in your
introductory plant reading class with
these two different kinds of
conceptualizations of fitness
right with the idea of we want something
where there's no
g by e right or there where there's
something with a predictable g by e
and so and so this is really
where where we started and leading to
the question of
you know what is the real benefit
of local adaptation to commercially
available crops
because we have two different
conceptions of stability
we have uh and we want to know which one
is
actually winning because plant
breeding's been fantastic
and ag's been fantastic over the last
100 years
of increasing crop production but are we
leaving some of this yield on the table
so the first study system is corn
we took the university of illinois corn
yield trials from 1999 to 2018
and uh uh for just for a slight
digression
um for for all the students there
this the idea for this came about
because i was uh i just given a talk
uh in in 2018
and uh i got asked a question
by um but by a friend of mine and then
after
after the uh we were talking about it
after the seminar
and uh the the the question was based
on an offhand comment i'd made saying
that well you can think of breeding as
as accelerated local adaptation and the
question was
uh from from my friend was well can you
and so then we decided to test it
and so this this university of illinois
data set was there because it was easily
acceptable
and it was uh 230 varieties over 216
site years
and it's their yield trials and so there
are some problems
right it's essentially uh can be viewed
as a reciprocal transplant experiment
uh there's 12 locations and obviously
only the checks are at some locations so
just to make sure to do some you know
truth checking the first thing we did
was basically look at our increases in
yield over time
are we seeing increases what are the
yield and what are the yield increases
that we're seeing
over time and much like you'd expect
yields are increasing you know on
average by
0.2 megagrams per hectare per year so
now we wanted to conceptualize how do we
figure out what this local adaptation is
so we tried to partition the variance
so first we have our effective genotype
we have obviously we have our yield and
we have
um our site year and our site year
interaction but we want to get it
again what is this kind of advantage you
have
in your most optimal environment so we
added this is home and home is the
location that is the best
relative performance right and it's
centered and scaled within
it within the site year and then and
then
uh we have right our unexplained
measurement error which is going to be
our g byte
so the in this in this
case right um
our coefficient for his home is our home
field advantage
and it allows us to say
it allows us to look at if we're looking
at this specific
site how big is the advantage of being
the best
uh the best yielder there
so um the the easiest thing is to just
look at the partitioning
of our of our variants here and the home
field advantage
is about 20 um
of the so basically about about 20 of
the original residual
g by e variation uh is
uh per location predicts uh you know is
from the corn yield so what this what
this actually
means is that you're getting a yield
increase
of about one uh
one megagram per hectare uh in your home
field site and that's a 7.6
increase relative to the mean right and
so you can see that the home field
advantage
varies per year but
on uh that we're we're still seeing
uh the home field advantage actually
while it varies it doesn't really change
per year
um and then uh just
uh to to basically check
our uh the truthiness right we did we
did a permutation test right um
to promote permute our site years and
basically we're preserving the psych and
year effects and randomizing the
genotypes
and and we're not really and um
we're not uh
uh we're we're seeing basically that
we're
we're seeing our uh are our expected
uh a home field advantage what we are
seeing as well though
is that especially specialization came
with the trade off so what you're seeing
here is our home field advantage
and our variance in yield right so as
we're
increasing our home field advantage
we're also
increasing the variability which of
course
is uh non-desirable but
what what we really saw is that this
idea
we're leaving yield on the table in our
local environment
and so basically it gets back to this
idea of what
conception of stability that we want do
we want this
broadly adapted where yield is going to
be less but it's going to be
the same or whether we're going to be
seen
or do we want to maximize it for a given
multiplication
but there's some obvious problems with
this analysis
right is our definition of home field
believable
or is it tautological so are we assuming
our conclusion in the
pres in the premise right um
so we actually think uh
that it's believable because home sites
almost all of the sites are represented
as home sites for some of the uh
for for some of the genotypes and if you
do leave one out analysis
the home sites generally jump to the
closest
site that we had
and and part of this actually led to um
a large debate amongst us on
a lot of fitness measurements in general
tend to be a little bit tautological so
that's why in the end we were okay with
it
the second problem which is which is
another
big one is we didn't control for genetic
relationships
right we didn't have any information on
the lines that were put in these trials
um and we didn't we didn't have a way of
getting it because these were all
commercial company cultivars that were
in those yield trials
so we were excited but we were also
you know rightfully skeptical of some of
these results the idea that
that that you you know this
7.6 or one megagram you know
uh per per hectare uh increase
if you're focusing that bad cultivar
we were intrigued but we wanted to
explore another system
right so we moved to common beam
so we moved to common bean um
uh sorry uh there's a chat here
oh for for any line in the trials for
greater than one year can you determine
the home site in one year and test in
the other years
yeah we actually we actually can um
uh uh john we should do that we haven't
done that yet
and that that is actually that's a
really good idea we should do that
with this bean data set thank you
um but so so this is so so this was
uh alice mcqueen uh had published this
great paper in genetics
um looking at the cooperative dry bean
nursery trials
so this is actually 2170 site years from
1981 to 2013
um planted at uh 71
locations across canada and the us
um you can see all the sites you can see
all the sites here
um and we wanted to see
okay here's a system where we know the
genetic relationships everything's been
genotyped
it's a longer time series over a wider
geographic range
with more sites so we decided to try
the same analysis and and there are
obvious differences but this let us get
at some of the questions that we had
um regarding the obvious flaws in our
previous analysis
so the first oh the first thing we did
was again just make some basic checks
let's plot
our um uh yield
increases over time which ends up being
about a half a percent per year what
you're
seeing in our different lines in this
case are these are the
the major uh races of uh
common being uh durango and mesoamerican
are from a domestication event in mexico
and um
granada is a is a south american
domestication
so in our conceptualization of this we
basically use our same
uh quantile regression that we used
before only we're adding a couple of
different terms
um we actually explicitly
now are trying to model the home field
advantage by the different domestication
events
we're also explicitly adding in
covariates
uh for the genetic structure and the
relationships that we have
um between uh
all of these genotypes
and what we actually see
i apologize that these aren't donuts
as everyone should know i would much
prefer donuts but
but less easy to display with the three
different
um with the three different uh
germplasm pools here but basically what
we saw is actually a much smaller home
field advantage
um so what we saw is uh basically the
uh home the home site advantage uh
accounted uh for a little more than one
percent of that total variation
um and about six and a half percent of
the residual variation
still highly significant the uh the
the genetic relationships uh when you
include them as covariates in the model
were
not actually significant and didn't
explain
much variation at all uh so we were
happy about that
um but uh
we were uh we thought it was interesting
well we're explaining
um we're explaining a lower magnitude
but um actually this was
uh this lower magnitude was of greater
importance
uh because um
instead of being about a three to four x
uh difference in yield
uh you uh you could uh in that yield
gain
over year over year here that oh year
over year gain
the home field advantage was actually uh
13 times greater than that so we were
excited about that
um we actually saw the same trends that
we saw
uh everywhere else that that the change
in home field advantage
was pretty stable uh over time
uh none of these lines are and none of
these regressions are actually
uh significant um we did
see uh that uh
a different a different trend uh in
terms of the home field advantage
uh and the increasing variability here
in the sense
that only for that durango group did
did we see that kind of expected
increase in
variation uh
that increase in variation over
uh as home field advantage increase
so we're actually pretty happy we were
able to figure out
some problems with our previous analysis
we were to look over a larger time frame
over a larger site number of sites over
a larger geographic
extent and we have a very similar story
where were
the in breeding for broad adaptation
we are potentially leaving some yield on
the table
and uh economically significant yield on
the table
but it doesn't get to the other half of
that question
so what is then the size
what is local right a common question
that i'm sure everyone
that everyone here has come across so
one thing that we decided to look at was
the spatial variability inheritability
so what you're looking at here
is an ordinary kriging across all of the
sites
except the puerto rico site the puerto
rico site
is a bit of an outlier and causes weird
things
we dropped it from this particular um
well actually we dropped it from all the
analysis because it just it behaves a
bit strangely
um so so what you're seeing is this is
actually the
the uh the ordinary creatine averaged
over
all uh 30 years and and what what you're
seeing
in this case is um
actually our highest heritabilities in
the regions where breeding has been most
intense
um and and uh
obviously that leads to some ideas
as to um you know where breeding might
be most effective
but one of the interesting things about
this analysis
is when you look at the semivariogram at
the the decay
inheritability the decay inheritability
is
um a thousand kilometers so right so
about 300 miles
so looking at the decay of where
selection is going to be most effective
and by most effective i i'm looking at
it in terms of if i have a high
heritability
i'll be able to to do quite a bit more
uh it it really
we started to get a picture of well our
home field advantage
and our ability to select is really
going to be
[Music]
in this narrower geography which is
still a pretty broad geography of 300
miles but that that
um
we we were actually quite intrigued by
that
and we were we also started looking at
again this idea of the variance
inheritability measures
uh relative to the um
the the magnitude of heritability and it
turns out
um not unexpectedly uh
that um about a third of the sites
uh about actually more about 40 of the
sites are just garbage
because the variance inheritability is
actually
either of the same magnitude or greater
than the heritability estimates
themselves over time
so you really you can use it as a yield
trial but it's not a terribly useful
selection environment
because you know your heritability is
effectively zero
um but we also wanted to check kind of
the troopiness
uh and look at our heritability
estimates over time
and so we did it right and so
what you're seeing here is a sliding
window of heritabilities on a line mean
basis for
for five years going from 1983
to 2011 and we
wanted to see if this matched our
general expectations on breeding
uh uh for for the germplasm so what
you're seeing here
in in the mesoamerican is actually
you're seeing a decrease in heritability
over time
and this matches what we expect in
common being
because um what we have
is there's been a decrease in genetic
diversity uh
in the mesoamerican lines over time
they've been and and so this matches
what we expect
basically while the mean in the
population's improved the genetic
variance is decreased so it's harder to
make gains
now than it was in the past and actually
in our indian lines here we've seen the
opposite trend there's been a lot of
introduction
uh from what alice tells me in term uh
from
these other germplasm pools into
the andean germ plasma pool so what
we're actually seeing here
is more a higher uh an increase in
heritability because
of this increased um diversity
so we were happy about this
that basically matched what our
expectations are
um another analysis that i
that i haven't done yet but i'm really
excited to do
is actually partition all of the sites
over time into these 300 mile bins
and see basically uh
what what what type of variants we're
seeing
as we ban it by what we basically by
what that semivariogram is going to say
on what the optimal size for selection
would be
so what does this actually mean
we have actually the same conclusions
when explicitly controlling for genetics
and domestication
history and it's a deficit of local
adaptation
that's not unexpected we expected
to see broad adaptation that's what
we've selected for
um but what uh
what um i would tend to argue
is that for some local markets
you can actually gain from explicitly
shrinking that breeding program
and uh and looking at specific
localities and again
in rnd our yields tend to be lower but
they yield more consistently
the mesoamericans tend to have higher
yields but are more variable
but i promised you two topics didn't i
um hopefully i've convinced you that
breeding broad adaptation
you know we've really seen we've limited
yield potential and maybe we want to
rethink that
particular strategy um uh especially
uh under if you have resource
constraints in the public sector
i want to convince you that that because
of those resource constraints that
breeding for small geographies
and markets can increase revenue right
so
let's talk about hawaii let's talk about
canoe plants and why
so the polynesians uh arrived in hawaii
uh about 1100 years ago the the
archaeological
estimates i think uh are
some go back up to 300 years ago but i
think around 1100 is
about the consensus um they were great
plant breeders and great
agriculturalists they
they you know they had they brought lots
of plants
medicinal plants cava food plants yam
coconut taro bread fruit um
and and and sugar cane uh also sweet
potato
and in these large voyaging canoes that
took them all over
oceana these
particular crops have a deep place in
the epistemology
of hawaii and many of the polynesian
cultures
um and they're also they've also had
great uh monetary benefits uh
to hawaii and other other polynesian
nations
but because of the value um
that they that they've had this has uh
led to some problems right universities
have behaved badly in the past
there's been a history of biopiracy
there's been disrespective traditional
knowledge
um and and this work is is
documented by a colleague here at uh
aurora kagawa viviani if you guys are
interested in her paper
i'm happy to send it to you um but
basically a disrespectful traditional
knowledge
um and also the monetizing of
traditional knowledge both from
medicinal and drug plants to um
the use of uh uh of
of crop plants and and this
uh this has led to in hawaii
uh quite a bit of uh bad blood the the
most recent
case at the university of hawaii was
with the patenting
of tarot varieties
both some gm varieties that were
ultimately
destroyed and but also some
conventionally bred tarot varieties
which tarot again in the epistemology
of hawaii is incredibly important
so wanted to kind of
do something a little bit different but
um
this this this this history basically
uh it can be capitalized or is not
capitalized basically this idea of
monetizing the traditional
knowledge because in hawaii things that
are from hawaii
get get a huge price premium uh not not
only
among locals but also among tourists so
the approach that we basically took
was uh a colleague of mine uh
ted ravich um has been work uh
is been working uh
in hawaii for years and he's um
very involved in what's called the the
waimanalo pono research
louis so waimanalo is one of our
research stations
um and the the the the pono resource
virtually
is it's a community organization um
of all of mostly native hawaiians but
also many
people who just grew up and lived in
hawaii and
they they've partnered with they
partnered with many other organizations
and they do community outreach they do
scholarly work
um and they do a lot of primary and
secondary education
so what what you're seeing here in this
picture is this is a picture of the
of uh the the research station
and this is actually where the the the
research really holds a lot of its event
uh at the um uh events on the station
so basically working with
them we decided to do some breeding
in traditional hawaiian sweet potato
so uh that that that's
kind of the name varieties that were
associated with
uh sweet potato production um
prior basically during the time of the
hawaiian kingdom
the kingdom of hawaii and before so um
again so a student uh here are some of
the initial
uh botanical sketches from the 40s of
two
uh varieties uh right here uh mohihi and
ella
so some recent work in economic botany
um
by elizabeth winnicken and aurora aurora
if you got with viviani again
looked at um basically the ethnobotany
of hawaiian sweet potatoes
so what you're seeing here on the left
is just um
a k-means clustering of um
about a hundred different varieties and
and really what you're seeing is if you
look at the k
k equals three cluster here um
you're seeing um uh
that that all that a lot of
uh the hawaiian individuals here
sorry i'm trying to draw a circle but
it's not letting me there
uh the the hawaiian germplasm is unique
right it's basically it's it's distinct
from what's in the usda collection it's
distinct from a lot of other collections
so there is considerable value to the
hawaii
to having the hawaiian names but also to
breeding
only within this particular group and
not doing any progressions
in terms of the idea of hawaiian
heritage varieties
so basically very standard breeding
hawaiian varieties were put in a
polycross block
all the f1s were grown out we did
uh initial selections this initial
selection was interesting so this was
done
all the plants were dug up they were all
laid out all
uh from f1 hills and the community
helped judge
what was uh so it's basically community
selection we like this shape we don't
like this color um
we the this one this one uh we don't
like the leaves lots of different
different traits some that i wouldn't
have thought were important but
but were right um so this led to
basically
uh of of uh the several hundred f-ones
we ended up with sixteen the community
really liked
we grew them out in a specific trial
and a series of trials actually these
were the ones and
uh uh against basically our maternal
parents
uh which was mohihi and the commercial
check here which is okinawa
um we had four we had three that
performed as well
or better than the check and then
everyone
just loves this hm17 so
hm stands for hapa moji because we only
kept track of our maternal apparent
milky
um hapa being mixed
so for whatever reason the
people really love this hm17 so even
though it is a terrible yielder
we're keeping it around because the
community really liked it
and um basically
we can get a huge price premium
for hawaiian heritage varieties
in in the fresh market and it and and
what ends up happening is that
we can build a tremendous amount of
goodwill
with the community um because they're
they're involved with the specific
species that they like
so uh that's important to the community
so our winners um where this hm 34
which looks very very similar to okinawa
only with the difference
in skin color uh hm 26
is interesting because it's a monster
but they uh just tremendous yield
doesn't taste very good
but uh it's used for for brewing
it's it's used to make a um
um a sweet potato beer so that's that's
where
people have been are interested in that
one
um are our lines 32 and 17
um i happen to just really like 32 that
that really nice purple color
um the that that kind of unique
peach for that hm17 is i think why
people
have really have really liked it but it
again it's i'm
i'm not a big fan of that one personally
the more interesting piece is how we
decided to do a release policy
um so there's actually
scheduled for the beginning of may or
the
yeah it's the beginning of may um
there's going to be a community tasting
and naming gathering with the
researchery
so there's going to be sweet potato
cooked in many different ways along with
the sweet potato beer
and the royalty plan is something quite
different than what you'd expect for a
normal variety release
so the kknoww is the nonprofit
um that the waimanalo research hui is
under
um and basically the royalty plan
is to have the royalties
go to um
the the community organization that that
uh has been helping us with the
selection
uh 50 is going to cover
ongoing community activities which
include maintaining the lines
at the uh at the station and then
25 would go to uh directly to the to the
station where all the breeding
activities were taking place
so um
the the idea here is really a new
royalty
to have a royalty plan that
um acknowledges the the
the basically participatory nature of
this
it's unclear it's unclear how much
revenue
will be generated but it certainly
regardless of how much revenue it has
been great
as a community building activity and
also
as a recruitment activity because there
are you know a lot of
kids who actually participate um
in the on station activities um
so what can we take away from these
three vignettes
uh being corn sweet potato
three different crops
but hopefully uh you know
kind of one story right
the story is that
through design right through selecting
for broad adaptation
we've left yield on the table we can
reclaim that yield
through having more targeted brini
programs um
there are certainly large markets for
niche for for for regional and and
specific crops in this case i would say
the hawaiian sweet potato um
but i think we have a lot of questions
right
um how are we going to deploy
populations of crops
you know how are we going to perform uh
in the case of the sweet potato which
would be end up being
a lot of small holdings you know on very
heterogeneous environments how are they
going to perform in kind of those low
capital systems how can you leverage if
we're saying that we're
having very strong local uh
yield effects right how are we going to
leverage site-specific management
in higher capital systems and
with the increased variance that's
obviously seen with the
well with the increased variance that we
see with the increased local adaptation
how is that going to change the capital
investment and how is that going to
perform
you know reliably in more unstable uh
environments right in climates
so hopefully i've convinced you
right that uh that local
has a lot of benefits especially for
very small markets like
like hawaii um so with that right
i'd like to thank uh all the people who
uh you know work on this i um
you know brian tom cono patrick uh
ewing alice colin curry ted radovich
uh todd anderson jk bingham the weimanal
research relief
lots of different organizations texas
sea
uh uh university of minnesota oregon
state
um uh you know
jeff and lex for for uh for
for for helping us think through some of
these things
um yeah and so
hopefully you guys believe that you can
you can
you can get that home field advantage
and really improve
uh improve yield in some of these
specific circumstances
so with that hopefully you guys have
some questions
and yeah i'm looking forward to talking
so so i was curious um one of the one of
the ways that's really common to assess
local adaptation is to sort of correlate
performances with uh
environmental uh variables like climate
or something like that so
yeah that can be a lot more nuanced than
home field advantage so
did you did you look at that yeah so for
the for the
for the porn we did right and so you can
uh you saw basically you saw
a rainfall gradient right so it's a
precipitation gradient and you saw
you saw different cultivars perform
better in the different precipitation
regimes
um when
you uh plus so basically
yeah so we haven't done it yet for the
bean but i can tell you we're gonna
what we basically see there um
i haven't formally done it there but
what we what you see is a temp as a
temperature gradient it's latitudinal
gradient
right um that um probably also has to do
with flowering time but it's also it's
very much a temperature and a
seasonality thing there
um so i think you're
right and so i would what i would say
is the question is one of responsiveness
how quickly can you
respond to a potential change
and and so yeah so that that's what i
would say hopefully that answers at
martin
yeah i think that actually leads right
into a question ed put in the chat
ed did you want to oh
yeah i was uh making really enjoyed it
but i was
in the face of climate change you know
as
you know we may be moving to a period
where things are moving
50 miles to 100 miles
of adaptation per decade how do you
think about balancing out those
types of things yeah so i think
a lot of it depends on what scale you
you decide you want to work at
and what is your specific question so i
know that that's an unhelpful answer and
i apologize but i think
i think the reason breeding for broad
adaptation
is such a successful strategy is because
it is
it it that conception of stability where
you're having basically where you're
trying to eliminate that genotype by
environment interaction
hedges all your bats right um
and i think the conception where we're
leaving yield on the table and you have
a smaller regional breeding
program is uh
i think if you're moving in a decade for
some of these annual crops i don't think
that's a problem
right where you can i mean i guess i'm
thinking of chili pepper right i can get
four generations
in a year right so if i want to move
that
it's it's possible obviously much harder
for longer term perennials
you know where they're in the ground for
10 years or something but
um i
think in some ways
you could again poke holes in in this
particular analysis by saying it's kind
of a
um it's a problem that is
based uh on kind of having an
embarrassment of riches
right um where because you're you're
worried about completely optimizing
yield
you're not worried so much about hedging
um
yeah so i think
you know like a lot of things you're
going to see a mix of strategies
depending on what the most pressing
concern is for your geography
i would also argue that you know again a
decay of 300 miles is still a pretty
big area um so
that you you still have quite a bit of
wiggle room
uh so i have have you uh have you
partitioned stability across locations
and stability across
years does home field advantage
influence both um
yes so we definitely have partitioned
stability um uh
across years i don't remember doing it
specifically for locations
um and uh no home field advantage didn't
really
impact that uh which surprised me
um the the the home field advantage
that was basically the same in bad years
and good years um that the average home
field advantage across
sites we should really do that by
sites because i would bet by sites
that's not the case
and i would bet specific sites when they
have a bad
year um
so for the average site it doesn't but
for the individual site it most
certainly would
when you have a bad year the home field
advantage
is is not going to be there um
uh so hopefully kelly that answered your
question um
so jean-luc how do you account for the
geographic radiant inheritability
um sorry the the chat just jumped on me
uh the the the geographic radio
inheritability for common green 3d
programs get better as you move from the
southwest to the northwest so low
lower error variants uh northwest
further away from the environments of
origin of being and so novel variation
revealed in new
environments so i would the way that i
actually think about this is that a lot
of the
the sites a lot of the original bit of
breeding
was done in the northwest and
uh this big network of sites
i think what use what we ended up seeing
is uh that uh
the the breeding programs in the
northwest were better funded and
just didn't do better so i think that
that is accurate
um and uh
yeah and so this has been the the
northwest being
further away from the environments of
origin
we've been uh so if anyone has good
ideas on that side please let me know i
i think what alice and i
uh and patrick have been talking about
is that might be
that's also where a lot of the
mesoamerican bean breeding is being done
and so we're wondering if that might be
one reason why we're seeing a larger
bottleneck there basically in
domestication because you selected for
individuals that work there um
and so i think that that might have
something to to do with it but it's
uh not not entirely clear and
um it's one of the questions we're we're
trying to
to answer uh but yeah i think that's
really really cool so um
so following on so from sorry so from
uh arcadio i apologize if i'm not
pronouncing that correctly
uh following on john luke's question
could the geographic gradient uh
on heritability be a reflection of
environmental
uh variability um
so the northern locations experiencing
less disturbing environment fluctuations
due to the shorter potential growing
season
um that's a good question
i think that
that's probably not the case i think the
reason we're seeing
a gradient in the heritability and that
decreasing
gradient is that um
there is actually significant
differences
on a year for for as you do that sliding
window
um there are significant differences in
year
i think that
it has more to do with
um i think it has more to do with trial
construction and the error associated
with the individual trials just looking
at the way
the just looking at the variances by
sight and by
um over time so i think it i
don't think it has to do so much with
the um
the environmental fluctuations um
that would be really hard to test but
it'd be really cool so the way that the
way that i would conceptualize doing
that is you'd actually have to get
seasonality data and look at planting
and harvest states and then you would
actually take the environmental data
associated with
the growing season and then partition
that out as an additional covariate and
see what that relationship would be
so that might be possible i'll i'll ask
alice if we have those dates because
that'd be really cool
um so the more leap breathing uh
the more leap breathing the germplasm
has been through the more you expect low
differentiation
um yes so my expectation right is
that uh for those for for the moral
elite at least in this case the
expectation was we're going to have a
much higher mean performance but the
genetic variance associated
with that breeding um with
with that breeding population is going
to be lower um
obviously that was that that's based on
alice's experience
working with these working with these
lines and the two different breeding
pools
um so that's where those expectations
came from for the mesoamerican
and the indian germplasm um
i think that that in general is going to
be fairly crop specific
um so will the sweet potato community
model be used for other crops in hawaii
do you have suggestions for implementing
this model beyond
a model for crops grown in new york
state and beyond
that is a great question um so
we have been busy drafting
and re-drafting and re-redrafting
um the the cultivar release policy as it
relates to native hawaiian crops
the release policy for
non-native crops is completely standard
modeled on
uh from the model on the university of
florida
and from the um workshop that the
pvcc did at napb
like five or six years ago at nc state
um
what we eventually came up with and i'm
happy to share this with everyone
is at first it was very extensive
outlining
lots of different potential interactions
and then it got cut so basically now
it is a one paragraph statement
that says due to this relationship
between um
native hawaiians and native wine crops
each cultivar release associated with
the native hawaiian crop
is going to be vetted by
a basically a committee and the
committee is made up of
um native hawaiian uh scholars and
community members so from
department of hawaiian studies we have a
couple
native hawaiian faculty members um who
are
in ag who are on it and then and then
the dean of the college
and that's going to be the the goal for
for doing that um
the a generalizable policy across the
board was not something that we could
find an
agreement on and so the idea of having
that
uh be done in cooperation on a
case-by-case basis
seems to be the most appropriate way to
do it so that
so that it becomes a true community
back and forth with the university um so
i don't know cornell's history with
um i guess it would be
mostly the iroquois confederation in um
in northern new york there uh maybe iraq
i don't know um but but um but uh
the university has a really bad rep in
hawaii
and so it it there's a lot
that has to be restored in that
interaction so
more talking is better um oh thank you
rebecca
uh so others uh are asking about the
inter-annual variations
uh so so let's talk about the concept of
yield
in the context of leaving yield on the
table should we be thinking
of leaving value on the table uh the
sweet potato with low yield had high
value to people
which could be taken which could be
taken seriously in the
analysis that is a great point um
so we were seeing
leaving yield and leaving value on the
tables in the context of these being
commodities
and i think that you're exactly right
the value
isn't necessarily especially
in in the context of the sweet potato
the value didn't really
come from the yield um and so
um in fact that that best yielder
is just a source of carbohydrate right
it's not really
one that um it's it's really only
the the only folk folks who are really
interested in it are the brewers
because it's not great tasting right um
so i think you're right the idea of
what's going to bring value and what's
going to keep a local
breeding program going is a really good
question
the a big reason that
the participant that i'm taking the
participatory approach here
is because um
we don't have a lot of funds for
for stable stably doing things and so
the idea
of helping a community work on a crop
that they'll continue to breed that
they'll continue to grow up grow these
polycross blocks
germ i mean you get people you get
people
really into it and you get you get
basically the community on the station
interacting with the university
interested in growing plants and
um interested also in
in kind of maintaining that relationship
um
so for us it's a way to to
work to to release cultivars
in a way that even though the any of
those royalties might be minimal the
community impact is going to be
bigger we hope um
it's you know i i would love to take
more credit but i can't it's it's ted so
ted
ted grew up in waimanalo he's he's
he he grew up you know about you know 10
minutes away from the station
and this is a big thing that his program
has been doing
um that you know working in
uh he does a lot of work in sustainable
ag and you know for him
this is a huge part of the the
sustainability comes from the social
component
and making sure that everyone in the
community still wants to engage with ag
um and so i think that that is
correct so yeah i try to help hopefully
that answered your question rebecca
i think i should chime in here just to
say we've already gone a bit over the
time
uh it's fine with me but i know mikey i
think you've got some
some time with grad students coming up
for lunch
if there are no other questions thank
you so much it was super fascinating
yeah
thank you guys i i really it's just a
pleasure to be there and
i am happy to answer any questions and
and you guys just send me an email i
will and
hopefully answer right away
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu